university and google deepmind so delena
has been a pioneer researcher in
reinforced malaria and art and general
artificial intelligence
and she recently has done a lot of very
impressive work
on reinforcement learning theory and she
is not only a professor at mcgill and
also i think she's
leading a research team and google
deepmind is that right
that's correct yes okay yeah please it's
all yours
thank you uh thank you for the
invitation uh to speak at this workshop
i'm going to talk about some recent work
uh that is about to appear
in europe's uh that was spearheaded by
my phd student scott fujimoto
and it's also a joint collaboration with
david meager who's a robotics professor
at
mcgill and mila and
the work uh concerns experience replay
buffers and reinforcement learning and
we're going to discuss
an equivalence between loss functions
and non-uniform sampling
in experience reply so first of all just
a quick
refresher what is experience replay
it's a technique that is very widely
used in reinforcement learning agents
that use function approximation
and the idea is that the agent interacts
with the environment
but then this interaction the samples of
states actions rewards and next states
actually gets stored into a buffer which
you have here
on the screen and then whenever the
agent wants to train
is going to sample some mini batches
from this buffer
uh we use the data in the mini batch to
do an
update um and then uh it's going to
continue this process and so
we really have uh you know
while the agent is interacting online
with the environment we really actually
have
a memory of its experience and we're
going to keep
sampling uh from that memory
and in some sense this is a trick that
was initially uh introduced by longitude
and back in 1990 he was a roboticist
and he uh just wanted to make sure that
data did not get lost because it's very
expensive to produce
and also he wanted to make sure that if
his robot
somehow happened upon a really good
trajectory
that it would um use that trajectory
sufficient amount of time to really
learn from it
um the this trick was popularized really
by
uh the qan uh in which
uh was motivated actually uh by attempts
to
make reinforcement learning more like
supervised learning
and so to ensure that
reinforcement learning agents didn't
have so much correlation
in the data that they were training on
make the samples more id which makes
these agents better suited uh to use
deep neural networks and another sort of
side effect of this
is that it ensures that older experience
that the agent might have had
before doesn't completely get forgotten
so in other words if the agent has
visited some part of the state's
pace and then moved away from there if
data from that part of state space is
still in the replay buffer
the agent is still um going to uh to be
able
um to uh to rehearse on that data
now there are different ways to uh
control the replay buffer and so
by controlling the replay buffer what we
mean is
which samples do we get uh which of
these
samples here are we going to get from
this free play buffer
and of course the the simplest thing to
think about is to do uniform sampling
you just like
sample at random uniformly at random uh
some number of examples those form a
mini batch and that goes to the agent
and the agent
uh trains on this data um
another popular technique is
recency-based sampling this is
more akin to traditional online
reinforcement learning where the recent
samples
are more emphasized compared to the
older samples
one technique that was introduced by my
colleague
deepmind tom schall and and others
is called prioritized experience replay
and
the approach there is to sample
preferentially uh
examples or transitions that exhibit
high temporal difference learning error
now why would that be useful well if if
there's height
tdr on a particular example that means
that we have the potential to learn a
lot from this example because our
previous prediction was
quite wrong and so sampling that data
over and over again gives the agent the
chance to learn a lot and intuitively
if we have an example that we sample a
lot it's
tdr is going to reduce and then some
other examples will become
um sort of more popular in this replay
buffer and will get sampled more
uh so this idea can be viewed actually
as a sample-based version of prioritized
sweeping which was an
algorithm introduced by uh andrew moore
back in the mid 90s
in the context of dynamic programming
algorithms
the idea there was to prioritize
updating certain states where
their their next state had received a
big update and so here we can think of
this
as the same idea but we would like to do
this in a sample based way
now using prioritized experience replay
is
very popular has empirically proven to
be much more successful than uniform
sampling
however it is somewhat more cumbersome
to implement because now we need to have
a priority queue for the examples and
they have to be
resorted in this priority queue and also
of course the td error can be kind of
noisy
and so that may lead to some amount of
variance in the updates as well
so what we're going to to do now is uh
discuss one fairly simple uh
but powerful idea which is that
prioritized experience replay
is equivalent in expectation to using
uniform sampling but with a modified
loss function
um and so the implication of this result
is that we
can actually replace a prioritized
buffer
with a regular buffer where we do
uniform sampling we're just going to
need to modify
the update that happens uh on each
transition
the non-uniform sampling might still be
in theory reducing variance but
empirically actually
it turns out to be quite similar and
sometimes worse than this approach of
using uniform sampling
and of course we can take this idea and
then implement it
in algorithms and so we have in the
paper
uh two algorithms that are described
one which uh sort of simplifies
prioritize the experience three play
based on this idea
and one which uses the uniform sampling
equivalent
which we call pow and we're going to
show some empirical results
both in mojoko as well as in atari tasks
so i will show you uh the main idea of
the paper and really that's kind of the
the important bit here and you know
otherwise there's uh there's a lot more
details but
um the main idea is the following
consider uh a particular transition the
ice transition that we've had
um and so now we're gonna denote by
delta i the prediction error that's
computed here so that could be
uh tdr for uh policy evaluation or it
could be a q learning error if we're
doing q learning
right basically whatever sort of error
your rl algorithm wants to compute on
the sample
suppose that we have some kind of a
generic loss function
this could be mean squared error or
huberized loss whatever it is
that we're usually uh estimating
okay so this takes the prediction error
maybe squares it
or computes its absolute value um
and now we want to estimate the expected
value of the gradient
under some sampling distribution b
okay and the gradient is taken with
respect to some parameters
uh parameters here are denoted q in
order to emphasize the relationship with
the value function
now suppose that actually we don't have
access
uh to q but we only have a
to b to the sampling distribution b but
instead we have access only to some
other sampling distribution d
is there a way to compute this
expectation
well uh we have a way that has been
established a long time ago
which is based on important sampling
right then the idea in important
sampling is that if we want to compute
an expectation with respect to summation
other measure
we can introduce here some important
sampling corrections
uh and then compute the expectation in
just the same way
and so we can we can do important
sampling on the gradient and if we have
uh access to p of b and pfd
then we can do these corrections and
of course we can compute these
expectations by sampling as well
all right so the intuition in this paper
is that in some cases we can
replace the content of the second
expectation
by a gradient of a different loss
function l2
okay and so if we had a way for the
gradient of l2
to match these important sample
corrected gradients of
l1 uh then we could actually
just do sampling from d compute to this
gradient with respect to
loss l2 and everything would be good
um and so uh okay this is
this is somewhat interesting but the
question is are there any
circumstances in which uh
this actually uh turns out to be a
computable loss or a loss that
that makes sense
and so one interesting situation to
consider here
is a relationship between uh the mean
squared error
and an l1 loss okay
and so uh if you imagine taking the
gradient
of a mean squared error of delta i delta
i
think of them as as tdrs okay
um what does this mean well when we take
the gradient
we can uh sort of uh compute what this
comes out to
and we end up with the expression here
which is basically an averaging
of um td errors
okay normalized by uh
by the absolute value of the tdr and so
this quantity here is actually
proportional just to the sign of the tdr
would just just have an
l1 loss on the tdr and so we go
from the expected gradient of a squared
error
to the expected gradient of an l1
uh error under a different distribution
okay and this distribution is the
distribution that we would obtain
uh by doing uh prioritized experience
replay
where the prioritization happens with
the absolute magnitude of the error
and so prioritized experience replay
could be achieved using uniform sampling
and the change in the error function as
as we see here
so this is the the key idea or this sort
of
uh example okay but we can of course
make this into a more uh general
theoretical result
and so the result is stated here
if we have two loss functions and some
priority scheme
which is denoted here pr
if we consider uniform sampling
we can obtain an equivalent
gradient by sampling with a prioritized
buffer and modifying the error function
so long as we have this relationship
between the gradients of
the two different error functions
and so uh this basically can be shown to
be true
uh if we have the relationship uh
between the two
loss functions that's described here in
equation 7.
and so in particular
we can use as a priority
the magnitude of the prediction error
delta and we
obtain a relationship that
is actually very weak between the two
functions
in particular if
the sign of the gradient of
the first loss using delta i
is equal to the sine of the gradient of
the second loss
on delta i and the priority is
given by the ratios of these two
gradients then the theorem
is always satisfied and so
uh while you know the special case that
we analyze in the paper
has to do with tdrs in fact one can
use this for really any kind of losses
including
for example eligibility traces versions
of
q-learning sarsa and so on
now another question is what
implications this has
on the variance and um
the variance of of the gradient actually
can be better in the uh
non-uniform sampling case really whether
the variances
is better or not actually depends on
the particulars of the priority scheme
and the loss function
and so now um we've actually also
derived a special corollary here
uh using uh huber loss uh
with prioritized experience replay um
and so we can actually derive
analytically
uh what loss we would need to use when
we have a uniformly sampled
uh buffer and that's that's the
expression here
um and so uh
one thing that that uh comes out of this
expression when we analyze this loss
uh is that prioritized experience replay
in fact is going to
be uh biased um something that's
a bit harder to see when you look at the
algorithm rather than
looking at this loss and
the bias is towards the median
of the samples rather than towards the
mean of the sample
okay um but
this bias is something that we can
actually control okay
by playing around with the way in which
the sampling happens and also
uh with uh with these uh hyper
parameters here
and so we can essentially we now have a
knob that allows us to do prioritized
experience replay
with a trade-off between its bias and
its very
so we've tried these algorithms
uh on several tasks one is a set of
mojoko environments which are depicted
here um
and we uh have as a base uh
algorithm uh td3 which was uh prior work
of scots we're also comparing against
soft after critic
um and now we can look at the algorithm
combined with
a prioritized experience replay as well
as
our two proposed algorithms one of the
algorithms is
just like prioritized experience replay
but
uh eliminates the bias and the other one
is a version of the algorithm
which basically
does this with a uniform buffer using
the loss function that we derived
and so what you see here is that
especially in the harder environments
like humanoid
uh these proposed algorithms are
actually uh quite a bit better
than the others and as expected
uh the two uh algorithms the sampled
versus non-sampled version are actually
pretty close to each other
um as uh of course as we would expect in
theory note though that the theory is
an expected uh version whereas here we
have of course
samples
we can look at atari results
here we are combining these ideas with
double dqa and so the blue lines are
double dq n
uh the orange lines are doubled the qn
plus prioritized experience replay and
then
again we can eliminate the bias of
prioritized experience replay and also
add this uniformly sampled buffer
and uh as before uh we can see that the
proposed algorithms
uh tend to be better not always but tend
to be better uh than the other versions
um you know there's
uh still issues of bias and variants
that crop
up but there are some environments like
frostbite for example
where these results are actually uh
quite significant
um we also include here a comparison
of the final performance uh in these
atari games and so here
we are looking at um
the proposed algorithms that we have and
we compare them against
double dqan plus prioritized experience
replay
and uh plain double dq1 um
and so uh these bars are the percentage
improvement
obtained over these two baselines and if
you see the bar going below zero that
means that actually we were worse
than than the baseline uh on those
particular domains
and so these are the um you know on the
x-axis you can see the different
environments that we have uh tried
and so what you can see is that there
are some cases where
uh the proposed versions of the
algorithms have quite significant
improvements there are also also some
cases
where uh they are worse
uh than the baseline so this is not
always a
guaranteed uh improvement um
but uh generally speaking uh controlling
for uh the bias uh tends to be
uh quite uh useful
um and so the tables here actually uh
summarize these results
um in numbers and looking all
at the mean and the median gain and you
can see that the improvement
is uh pretty significant
so i'm going to uh wrap up here um
the main message is that we now have
a nice and clean way to understand the
experience replay which also allows us
to do
uh an easy more streamlined incremental
implementation of the algorithm um
we have gotten some empirical experience
uh but more of course would be uh quite
beneficial
and also we haven't really explored
fully uh the space of possible losses
we've focused on this huberized loss
which is
typical of um the agents that are used
uh
in practice uh but actually exploring
the space of different
loss functions or that can be put on top
of the prediction error
uh could be quite interesting um one of
the things that
that i would like to think about in the
future is
actually um this issue of in fact
getting rid of replay buffers and i
think this is going to be a little bit
controversial
perhaps but of course the origins
of reinforcement learning were in
incremental learning where an agent can
interact with the environment and
immediately use those samples
and from that point of view the replay
buffer seems to be a kind of crutch
that an agent needs to use in order to
make sure that its updates are
actually stable um and so
uh it would be interesting to think
about whether
we can go back to a setup where we can
do
incremental updates on correlated data
data that is streaming in on a
trajectory
and still perform well with
neural networks and the loss functions
that we have
discussed actually give us some hope for
this because
these are loss functions that we can now
actually consider
sampling online as the data is
coming in so i'm going to
stop here and i would be happy to take
any questions
so gergas says i have a question
regarding the new law substituting the
huber loss does this loss inherit the
bounded gradient property of the huber
loss
um so that's a great question
and i think in the particular case that
we
looked at yes that is true but in
general for any pairs of losses that we
have that need not
uh be true uh and so that may need to be
an extra condition so if if instead of
thinking of of this particular huber
loss
we would think of uh something uh
of some other loss function i think we
would need to have a way
um to actually uh ensure
uh this uh this bounded gradient
property
okay uh thank you diana um yeah very
interesting talk
i think yeah i just want to clarify so
um
so the improvement in the algorithm is
to replace
uh prioritize experience replay with
uniform sampling with a different loss
right
hello i think we might have lost mindy
i think so yes hopefully she will
reappear
um i was also because maybe while
we're waiting for her um very nice talk
i was also curious a little bit of
whether
um maybe i missed it if you think this
also highlights whether we could do
other forms of like uniform resampling
with other types of loss functions that
might be even better
uh yes so i believe uh
it should be very straightforward to do
this
um you know what would be a good loss
function i think that
is very much an open question um and
so the tools that we have in the paper
perhaps give a way
of carrying out the analysis for other
loss functions that we might want to try
and other ways of prioritizing the
replay buffer but in general
what we want to optimize i think is very
much an
open question and may well be dependent
on
on the problem
do you cut out halfway yeah i dropped i
dropped the bar yeah i was going to ask
so
um so does this uh different
um sampling mechanism affect the
exploration part of the algorithm
so were you still using absolute greedy
exploration
or does the new sampling uh technique
allows like smarter exploration ah
that's a great question
uh we were still using epsilon greedy
and
uh you know we've tried uh entropy
regularized uh versions as well
um i so
yes in principle it could be possible to
leverage this
somehow in the exploration method uh
of course it's also perfectly easy to uh
combine something like for example
exploration bonuses to just fold it into
this algorithm
and we haven't really thought about this
problem
and it'd be a nice avenue i think for
uh for future work and then the notion
of
equivalence so that's an exact
equivalence
right so it's it's equivalence and
expectation
okay thank you
do we have other questions
i think i answered girgo's
questions
um okay all right
thank you very much okay
thank you okay um our